hello and welcome to k-nearest neighbors
algorithm tutorial my name is Richard
Kirchner and I'm with the simply learned
team today we're gonna cover the K
nearest neighbors a lot refer to as K in
n and k n n is really a fundamental
place to start in the machine learning
it's a basis of a lot of other things
and just the logic behind it is easy to
understand and incorporate it in other
forms of machine learning so today
what's in it for you
why do we need KN n what is KN n how do
we choose the factor K when do we use KN
n how does knn algorithm work and then
we'll dive in to my favorite part the
use case predict whether a person will
have diabetes or not that is a very
common and popular used data set as far
as testing out models and learning how
to use the different models and machine
learning by now we all know machine
learning models make predictions by
learning from the past data available so
we have our input values our machine
learning model builds on those inputs of
what we already know and then we use
that to create a predicted output is
that a dog little kid looking over there
and watching the black cat cross their
path no dear you can differentiate
between a cat and a dog based on their
characteristics cats cats have sharp
claws uses to climb smaller lengths of
ears meows and purrs doesn't love to
play around dogs have dull claws bigger
lengths of ears barks loves to run
around usually don't see a cat running
around people other why do you have a
cat that does that where dogs do and we
can look at these we can say we can
evaluate their sharpness of the claws
how sharper their claws and we can
evaluate the length of the ears and we
can usually sort out cats from dogs
based on even those two characteristics
now tell me if it is a cat or a dog
nod question usually little kids know
cats and dogs bite now listen them a
place where there's not many cats or
dogs so if we look at the sharpness of
the claws the length of the years and we
can see that the cat has a smaller ears
and sharper claws and the other animals
its features are more like
Katz's it must be a cat sharp claws
length of ears and it goes in the cat
group because KNN is based on feature
similarity we can do classification
using KNN classifier so we have our
input value the picture of the black cat
it goes into our trained model and it
predicts that this is a cat coming out
so what is KN n what is the KN algorithm
K nearest neighbors is what that stands
for
is one of the simplest supervised
machine learning algorithms mostly used
for classification so we want to know is
this a dog or it's not a dog is it a cat
or not a cat it classifies a data point
based on how its neighbors are
classified KN in stores all available
cases and classifies new cases based on
a similarity measure and here we gone
from cats and dogs right into wine
another favorite of mine KN in stores
all available cases and classifies new
cases based on a similarity measure and
here you see we have a measurement of
sulfur dioxide versus the chloride level
and then the different wines they've
tested and where they fall on that graph
based on how much sulfur dioxide and how
much chloride k and KN is a perimeter
that refers to the number of nearest
neighbors to include in the majority of
the voting process and so if we add a
new glass of wine there red or white we
want to know what the neighbors are in
this case we're gonna put k equals five
and we'll talk about K in just a minute
a data point is classified by the
majority of votes from its five nearest
neighbors here the unknown point would
be classified as red since four out of
five neighbors are red so how do we
choose K how do we know K equals five I
mean that's what is the value we put in
there and so we can talk about it how do
we choose the factor K knn algorithm is
based on feature similarity choosing the
right value of K is a process called
parameter tuning and is important for
better accuracy so at K equals three we
can classify we have a question mark in
the middle as either a as a square or
not is it a square or is it in this case
a triangle and so if we set K equals to
three we're going to look at the three
nearest neighbors we're going to say
this is a square and if we put K equals
to seven we classify as a triangle
depending on what the other data is
around and you can see is the K change
depending on where that point is that
drastically changes your answer and we
jump here we go how do we choose the
factor of K you'll find this in all
machine learning choosing these factors
that's the face you get he's like oh my
gosh you'd say choose the right K did I
set it right my values in whatever
machine learning tool you're looking at
so that you don't have a huge bias in
one direction or the other and in terms
of K n n the number of K if you choose
it too low the bias is based on it's
just too noisy it's right next to a
couple things and it's gonna pick those
things and you might get asked you to
answer and if your K is too big then
it's gonna take forever to process so
you're gonna run into processing issues
and resource issues so what we do the
most common use and there's other
options for choosing K is to use the
square root of n so it is a total number
of values you have you take the square
root of it in most cases you also if
it's an even number so if you're using
like in this case squares and triangles
if it's even you want to make your K
value odd that helps it select better so
in other words you're not going to have
a balance between two different factors
that are equal so you usually take the
square root of n and if it's even you
add one to it or subtract one from it
and that's where you get the K value
from that is the most common use and
it's pretty solid
it works very well when do we use KN n
we can use K n when data is labeled so
you need a label on it we know we have a
group of pictures with dogs dogs cats
cats data is noise free and so you can
see here when we have a class that we
have like underweight 140 23 Hello Kitty
normal that's pretty confusing we have a
variety of data coming in so it's very
noisy and that would cause an issue Dana
said is small so we're usually working
with smaller data sets where you might
get into gig of data if it's really
clean it doesn't have a lot of noise
because K and N is a lazy learner ie it
doesn't learn a discriminative function
from the training set so it's very lazy
so if you have very complicated data and
you have a large amount of it you're not
going to use the KNN but it's really
great to get a place to start even with
large data you can sort out a small
sample and get an idea of what that
looks like using the KNN and also just
using for smaller data sets
works really good how does a knn
algorithm work consider a data set
having two variables height and
centimeters and weight in kilograms and
each point is classified as normal or
underweight so we can see right here we
have two variables
you know true/false or either normal or
they're not they're underweight on the
basis of the given data we have to
classify the below set as normal or
underweight using KNN so if we have new
data coming in this says 57 kilograms
and 177 centimeters is that going to be
normal or underweight to find the
nearest neighbors we'll calculate the
Euclidean distance according to the
Euclidean distance formula the distance
between two points in the plane with the
coordinates XY and a B is given by
distance D equals the square root of x
minus a squared plus y minus B squared
and you can remember that from the two
edges of a triangle we're computing the
third edge since we know the x side and
the y side let's calculate it to
understand clearly
so we have our unknown point and we
placed it there in red and we have our
other points where the data is scattered
around the distance d1
is a square root of 170 minus 167
squared plus 57 minus 51 squared which
is about six point seven and distance
two is about 13 and distance three is
about 13 point four
similarly we will calculate the
Euclidean distance of unknown data point
from all the points in the data set
and because we're dealing with small
amount of data that's not that hard to
do it's actually pretty quick for a
computer and it's not really complicated
maths you can just see how close is the
data based on the Euclidean distance
hence we have calculated the Euclidean
distance of unknown data point from all
the points as showing where x1 and y1
equal 57 and 170 whose class we have to
classify now we're looking at they were
saying well here's a Euclidean distance
who's gonna be their closest neighbors
now let's calculate the nearest neighbor
at K equals 3 and we can see the three
closest neighbors put some at normal and
that's pretty self-evident when you look
at this graph it's pretty easy to say
okay what we're just voting normal
normal normal three votes for normal
this is gonna be a normal weight so
majority of neighbor
are pointing towards normal hints as per
knn algorithm the class of 57 170 should
be normal so a recap of KN n positive
integer K is specified along with a new
sample we select the K entries in our
database which are closest to the new
sample we find the most common
classification of these entries this is
the classification we give to the new
sample so as you can see it's pretty
straightforward we're just looking for
the closest things that match what we
got so let's take a look and see what
that looks like in a use case in Python
so let's dive in to the predict diabetes
use case so use case predict diabetes
the objective predict whether a person
will be diagnosed with diabetes or not
we have a data set of 768 people who
were or were not diagnosed with diabetes
and let's go ahead and open that file
and just take a look at that data and
this is in a simple spreadsheet format
the data itself is comma separated very
common set of data and it's also a very
common way to get the data and you can
see here we have columns a through I
that's what 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 8 columns
with a particular attribute and then the
ninth column which is the outcome is
whether they have diabetes as a data
scientist the first thing you should be
looking at is insolent well you know if
someone has insulin they have diabetes
that's why they're taking it when that
could cause issue and some of the
machine learning packages but for a very
basic setup this works fine for doing
the KNN and the next thing you notice is
it didn't take very much to open it up I
can scroll down to the bottom of the
data there's 768 it's pretty much a
small data set you know at 769 I can
easily fit this into my RAM on my
computer I can look at it I can
manipulate it and it's not gonna really
tax just a regular desktop computer you
don't even need an enterprise version to
run a lot of this so let's start with
importing all the tools we need and
before that of course we need to discuss
what IDE I'm using certainly you can use
any particular editor for python but i
like to use for doing very basic visual
stuff the anaconda which is great for
doing demos with the jupiter notebook
and just a quick view of the anaconda
navigator which
the new release out there which is
really nice you can see under home I can
choose my application we're gonna be
using Python three six I have a couple
different versions on this particular
machine if I go under environments
create a unique environment for each one
which is nice and there's even a little
button there where I can install
different packages so if I click on that
button and open the terminal I can then
use a simple pip install to install
different packages I'm working with
let's go ahead and go back on your home
and we're gonna launch our notebook and
I've already you know kind of like the
old cooking shows I've already prepared
a lot of my stuff so we don't have to
wait for it to launch because it takes a
few minutes for it to open up a browser
window in this case I'm gonna it's gonna
open up Chrome because that's my default
that I use and since the script is pre
done you'll see I have a number of
windows open up at the top the one we're
working in and since we're working on
the KNN predict whether a person will
have diabetes or not let's go and put
that title in there
and I'm also gonna go up here and click
on sell actually we want to go ahead and
first insert a cell below and then I'm
gonna go back up to the top cell and I'm
gonna change the cell type to markdown
that means this is not going to run as
Python it's a markdown language so if I
run this first one it comes up in nice
big letters which is kind of nice
mine just what we're working on and by
now you should be familiar with doing
all of our imports we're gonna import
the pandas as PD import numpy is NP
pandas is the pandas dataframe and numpy
is a number array very powerful tools to
use in here so we have our imports so
we've brought in our pandas our numpy or
to general python tools and then you can
see over here we have our train tests
split by now I used to be familiar with
splitting the data we want to split part
of it for training our thing and then
training our particular model and then
we want to go ahead and test the
remaining data to see how good it is pre
processing a standard scaler
preprocessor so we don't have a bias of
really large numbers remember in the
data we had like number of pregnancies
isn't gonna get very large where the
amount of insulin they taking it up to
256 so 256 versus 6 that will skew
results so we want to go ahead and
change that so that they're all uniform
between minus 1 and 1 and then the
actual tool this is the K neighbors
classifier we're going to
and finally the last three are three
tools to test all about testing our
model how good is it we just put down
tests on there and we have our confusion
matrix our f1 score and our accuracy so
we have our two general python modules
we're importing and then we have our six
module specific from the SK learn setup
and then we do need to go ahead and run
this so these are actually imported
there we go and then move on to the next
step and so in this set we're gonna go
ahead and load the database we're gonna
use pandas remember pandas as PD and
we'll take a look at the data in Python
we looked at it in a simple spreadsheet
but usually I like to also pull it up so
that we can see what we're doing so
here's our data set equals peed read CSV
that's a panda's command and the
diabetes folder I just put in the same
folder where my I python script is if
you put it in a different folder you
need the full length on there we can
also do a quick length of the data set
that is a simple Python command Elian
for length
we might even let's go ahead and print
that we'll go print and if you do it on
its own line links that data set that
you put a notebook it'll automatically
print it but when you're in most of your
different setups you want to do the
print in front of there and then we want
to take a look at the actual data set
and since we're in pandas we can simply
do data set head and again let's go
ahead and add the print in there if you
put a bunch of these in a row you know
the data set one head data set to head
it only prints out the last one so I
used to always like to keep the print
statement in there but because most
projects only use one data frame pandas
dataframe doing it this way doesn't
really matter the other way works just
fine and you can see when we hit the Run
button we have the 768 lines which we
knew and we have our pregnancies it's
automatically given a label on the left
remember the head only shows the first
five lines so we have zero through four
and just a quick look at the data you
can see it matches what we looked at
before we have pregnancy glucose blood
pressure all the way to age and then the
outcome on the end and we're gonna do a
couple things in this next step we're
going to create a list of columns where
we can't have zero there's no such thing
as zeros
in thickness or zero blood pressure or
zero glucose any of those you'd be dead
so not a really good factor if they
don't if they have a zero in there
because they didn't have the data and
we'll take a look at that because we're
gonna start replacing that information
with a couple of different things and
let's see what that looks like so first
we create a nice list as you can see we
have the values talked about glucose
blood pressure skin thickness and this
is a nice way when you're working with
columns is to list the columns you need
to do some kind of transformation on a
very common thing to do and then for
this particular setup we certainly could
use the there's some Panda tools that
will do a lot of this where we can
replace the n/a but we're gonna go ahead
and do it as a data set column equals
data set column don't replace this is
this is still pandas you can do a direct
there's also one that's that you look
for your n/a n/a a lot of different
options in here but the n/a n/a numpy na
n is what that stands for is is none
doesn't exist so the first thing we're
doing here is we're replacing the zero
with a numpy none there's no data there
that's what that says that's what this
is saying right here so put the zero in
and we're gonna play zeroes with no data
so if it's a zero that means a person's
well hopefully not dead oh they just
didn't get the data the next thing they
want to do is we're going to create the
mean which is the integer from the data
set from the column mean where we skip n
A's we can do that that is a pandas
command there the Skip ena so we're
gonna figure out the mean of that data
set and then we're gonna take that data
set column and we're gonna replace all
the N P na n with the means why did we
do that we could have actually just
taken this step and gone right down here
and just replace zero and skip anything
were except you could actually there's a
way to skip zeros and then just replace
all the zeros but in this case we want
to go ahead and do it this way so you
could see that we're switching this to a
non-existent value and we're gonna
create the mean well this is the average
person so if we don't know what it is if
they did not get the data and the data
is missing one of the tricks is you
replace it with the average what is the
most common data for that this way you
can still use the rest of those values
to do your computation and it kind of
just brings that particular
those missing values out of the equation
let's go ahead and take this and we'll
go ahead and run it doesn't actually do
anything so we're still preparing our
data if you wanted to see what that
looks like we don't have anything in the
first few lines so it's not gonna show
up but we certainly could look at a row
let's do that let's go into our data set
with a printed data set and let's pick
in this case let's just do glucose and
if I run this this is gonna pray on all
the different glucose levels going down
and we thankfully don't see anything in
here that looks like missing data at
least on the ones that show so you can
see you skipped a bunch in the middle
that's what it does we have two me lines
and Jupiter notebook he'll skip a few
and go on to the next and a data set let
me go and remove this will just zero out
that and of course before we do any
processing before proceeding any further
we need to split the data set into our
trained and testing data that way we
have something to train it with and
something to test it on and you're going
to notice we did a little something here
with the pandas data base code there we
go my drawing tool we've added in this
right here off the data set and what
this says is that the first one in
pandas this is from the PD pandas it's
gonna say within the data set we want to
look at the eye location and it is all
rows that's what that says so we're
gonna keep all the rows but we're only
looking at 0 column 0 to 8
remember column 9 here it is right up
here we printed it in here as outcome
well that's not part of the training
data that's part of the answer yes
column 9 but it's listed as 8 number 8
so 0 to 8 is 9 columns so 8 is the value
and when you see it in here 0 this is
actually 0 to 7 it doesn't include the
last one and then we go down here to Y
which is our answer and we want just the
last one just column 8 and you can do it
this way with this particular notation
and then if you remember we imported the
Train test split that's part of the SK
learn right there and we simply put in
our X and our Y we're gonna do random
state equals 0 you don't have to
necessarily seed it that's a seed number
I think the default is 1 when you seed
it I have to look that up and then the
test size test size is 0.2 that simply
means we're gonna take 20% of the data
and put it aside so that we can test it
later
that's all that is and again we're gonna
run it not very exciting so far we
haven't had any printout other than to
look at the data but that is a lot of
this is prepping this data once you prep
it the actual lines of code are quick
and easy and we're almost there but the
actual running of our KNN we need to go
ahead and do a scale the data if you
remember correctly we're fitting the
data and a standard scaler which means
instead of the data being from you know
five to three hundred three in one
column and the next column is one to six
we're gonna set that all so that all the
data is between minus one and one that's
what that standard scaler does keeps it
standardized and we only want to fit the
scaler with the training set but we want
to make sure the testing set is the X
test going in is also transformed so
it's processing at the same so here we
go with their standard scaler we're
gonna call it SC underscore X for the
scalar and we're gonna import the
standard scalar into this variable and
then our X train equals SC underscore X
dot fit transform so we're creating the
scalar on the X train variable and then
our X test we're also going to transform
it so we've trained and transformed the
X train and then the X test isn't part
of that training it isn't part of that
of training the Transformer
it just gets transformed that's all it
does and again we're gonna go and run
this if you look at this we've now gone
through these steps all three of them
we've taken care of replacing our zeros
four key columns that shouldn't be 0 and
we replace that with the means of those
columns that way that they fit right in
with our data models we've come down
here we split the data so now we have
our test data and our training data and
then we've taken and we've scaled the
data so all of our data going in oh no
we don't trip we don't train the Y part
the why train and why test that never
has to be trained it's only the data
going in that's what we want to train in
there then define the model using K
neighbors classifier and fit the train
data in the model so we do all that data
prep and you can see down here we're
only going to have a couple lines of
code where we're actually building our
model and training it that's one of the
cool things about Python and how far
we've come it's such an exciting time to
be in machine learning because there's
so many automated tools
let's see before we do this let's do a
quick links' of and let's do why we want
let's just do length of Y and we get 7
or 68 and if we import math we do math
dot square root
let's do Y train there we go it's
actually supposed to be X train before
we do this let's go ahead and do import
math and do math square root length of Y
test and when I run that we get 12 point
409 I want to see show you where this
number comes from we're about to use 12
is an even number so if you know if
you're ever voting on things remember
the neighbors all vote don't want to
have an even number of neighbors voting
so we want to do something odd and let's
just take one away we'll make it 11 let
me delete this out of here this one the
reasons I love Jupiter notebook because
you can flip around and do all kinds of
things on the fly so we'll go ahead and
put in our classifier we're creating our
classifier now and it's going to be the
K neighbors classifier and neighbors
equal 11 remember we did 12 minus 1 for
11 so we have an odd number of neighbors
P equals 2 because we're looking for is
it are the diabetic or not and we're
using the Euclidean metric there are
other means of measuring the distance
you could do like square square means
value there's all kinds of measure this
but the Euclidean is the most common one
and it works quite well it's important
to evaluate the model let's use the
confusion matrix to do that and we're
going to do is a confusion matrix
wonderful tool and then we'll jump into
the f1 score and finally an accuracy
score which is probably the most
commonly used quoted number when you go
into a meeting or something like that so
let's go ahead and paste that in there
and we'll set the CM equal to confusion
matrix why test why predict so those are
the two values we're going to put in
there and let me go ahead and run that
and print it out and the way you
interpret this is you have the Y
predicted which would be your title up
here you can do assist do PR IDI predict
it across the top and actual going down
it's always hard to write in here actual
that means that this column here down
the middle
that's the important column and it means
that our prediction said 94 and
prediction in the actual agreed on 94
and 32 this number here the 13 and the
15 those are what was wrong
so you could have like three different
if you're looking at this across three
different variables instead of just two
you'd end up with the third row down
here and the column going down the
middle so in the first case we have the
the and I believe the zero has a 90 for
people who don't have diabetes the
prediction said 213 of those people did
have diabetes and we're at high risk and
the 32 that had diabetes it had correct
but our prediction said another 15 out
of that 15 it classified as incorrect so
you can see where that classification
comes in and how that works on the
confusion matrix then we're gonna go
ahead and print the f1 score let me just
run that and you see we got 2 point 6 9
and our f1 score the f1 takes into
account both sides of the balance of
false positives where if we go ahead and
just do the accuracy account and that's
what most people think of is it looks at
just how many we got right out of how
many we got wrong so a lot of people in
your data scientists and you're talking
the other data scientists they're gonna
ask you what the f1 score the F score is
if you're talking to the general public
or the decision-makers in the business
they're gonna ask what the accuracy is
and the accuracy is always better than
the f1 score but the f1 score is more
telling let's just know that there's
more false positives than we would like
on here but 82% not too bad for a quick
flash look at people's different
statistics and running an SK learn and
running the KNN the K nearest neighbor
on it so we have created a model using
KN n which can predict whether a person
will have diabetes or not or at the very
least whether they should go get a
checkup and have their glucose checked
regularly or not the print accurate
score we got the point eight one eight
was pretty close to what we got and we
can pretty much round that off and just
say we have an accuracy of 80% tells us
that it's a pretty fair fit in the model
to pull that all together there's always
a lot of fun make sure we cover
everything we went over
we covered why we need a KN in looking
at cats and dogs great if you have a cat
door and you want to figure out where
there's a cat or dog coming in don't let
the dog in or out using Euclidean
distance the simple distance calculated
by the two sides of the triangle or the
square root of the two sides squared
choosing the value of K we discuss that
a little bit at least one of the main
choices that people use for choosing K
and how KNN works then finally we did a
full cane and classifier for diabetes
prediction thank you for joining us
today for more information visit
www.subscriptorium.com